hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at Mikhail tall's first recorded game
this was played in 1949 in a simul
against a master opponent ratmer kolmov
has the white pieces in this one against
a 12 year old Mikhail tall
let's have a look at it and see what I
found at least to not be surprising
about this game
starts off as a Queen's Gambit decline
now turned semi-slav with C6
after Bishop G5 white is one move out
with let's say E3
from being in the spot to
recapture on C4 conveniently
should black make that capture
well black does capture on C4 but while
this guy is still in home base
E4
and now B5 hanging on to the pawn
now
it is important black plays in this way
if your mentality right now is black is
you know I'm not materialistic I don't
mind if this Pawn is simply one back
it's the opening I'm supposed to develop
and you know what
I don't like being in a pin so let me
break it that's not good enough because
you would essentially be gifting white
uh giving white everything they could
really hope for out of the opening
white could do what
recapture develop these nights are on
their favorite squares ideal Pawn Center
and overall fantastic development
black must put up a much better fight
and does B5 I'm up a pawn you gotta work
harder to try and get it back
E5 now hits
trying to take advantage of the pin
tonight how do we get out of it we must
question the pinning piece
in this game Bishop takes Knight is
played
that's not the main line nowadays
Bishop backing off to H4 is keeping the
PIN
that would force
black to break the pin with G5
and then there's the sacrifice on G5 in
the end this Knight is one
back the material the minor piece is one
back
with the pawn
this guy
white star Square Bishop lives in the
main line
not in this game it's exchanged for
Black's night
Pawn takes and on this move 9 Bishop B4
is played pinning the Knight
one of the reasons I thought Bishop B4
is played to pin the Knight is
well if we take here is this going to be
annoying not really
Knight E4 would
be a terrible move in fact because
Bishop B4 check is in there and one of
these guys has to run in reverse
if you're blocking with this that would
hang D4 black is doing really well here
so this is considered a best move what
is
away black benefits by immediately
recapturing this Pawn well this guy
remains uncommitted for at least one
more move
will it be door a
or B it goes through there are lines
where it is deployed on the main
diagonal
okay it's committed straight away in
this game to B4
and the reply is Bishop to E2 sensible
enough
nothing
uh really wrong with Bishop to E2
it is the only door that's open for the
bishop so normally you have one door
open for the bishop you just go through
it
the recommendation is to actually invest
another Tempo in order to put the bishop
on the main diagonal
now
in what way can
white justify this additional tempo
well it is the longest diagonal from G2
it would Patrol the longest diagonal on
the board that's one two it would
observe a hole in Black's camp that has
been created ever since move six
C6 is the whole
when B5 was played C6 became a hole and
one final note
any major piece pressure that black may
look to one day exert along this half
open G file
is biting on a rock this Construction
is really strong for white
okay in this game
I only have one door open let me just go
through it
Queen takes Pawn only now
White Castles
this Knight is unpinned
black doesn't want to deal with any
night jumps at this stage
so chops the Knight
and continues to develop he's not
flipping a coin on this next one
with Knight D7 or Bishop to B7 Knight D7
first
with an I on this possibility
this is this Knight's next jump this is
a way for white to improve the pieces to
vacate
F3 as well for a bishop
to get on the main diagonal
if you play Bishop B7
this could be pretty irritating how you
dealing with this Knight
surprisingly enough the computer is
saying
still go here and be okay having your
king in the center okay that's
I don't like the looks of having the
king in the center like this so
important to watch out for the night
jump straight away on this move 12
Knight D7 does just that
A4 natural enough Rook pawns like to
attack Knight pawns Bishop B7 only now
and next up we have 95 so white still
jumps in there even though black has two
attackers on it white is giving up
another pawn and looking
to open the position this King
where's it gonna go where is it safe
haven
the night goes into E5 considered better
is to not be so quick to give a pawn up
another Pawn up but instead Retreat the
Knight not with the intention to go to
E4 but mainly to get this guy in the
main diagonal
okay
White's idea dive in the center give up
another Pawn the position is opening up
a bit more
and how to follow up now
as black well we have an open D file
with that last sequence white is giving
up the d-pawn
and black could now coordinate you might
say
much easier with his furthest Advanced
pun
look at the squares it's controlling so
this right here D3 that is a big pivot
Square
Rook d8
Queen C2
and black in this position
fully activates the Rook
so right now it's not a full Rook when
it's on d8 it's really only functioning
in a
T Direction but once it's planted right
here
it's a plus and it is fully activated
deep in White's house
okay from here a takes B5
and now in typical tall fashion we have
Rook takes Bishop
are we surprised by this the young tall
making a sacrifice on F3 his first
recorded game of course it's gonna be a
sacrifice
the king side is officially smashed
white does not recapture straight away
on F3
in this game Rook takes A7 is on board
how might play follow
if white captures The Rook
well black could give a check King has
to go to the corner
and then you take on B5 and what is
white doing about F3
It could only be defended
with the queen
D1 for instance but black is in a spot
to put a second attacker on it and this
will soon be leading to May
so first is Rook takes A7
Queen takes B5
defending the bishop Now The Rook is
captured but now
it's gonna be made soon enough
with Queen G5 check
ing H1
Rook G8
and white resigns there's no defense to
this queen coming into G2 for mate
trying to go for that Arrangement a
little bit earlier
meaning while this Rook was still on A1
white would have the defensive move Rook
G1 but there's only one Defender here
Rook G1 we could just capture The Rook
for mate there is in this position no
defense against the main threat
so a very smooth game a tactical finish
by the player who would soon become
known as the magician from Riga
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below I hope you enjoyed it
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care bye
yeah foreign